you know what we wouldn't have found we  wouldn't stand on the trail  what is that  the story people here know but don't  talk about  except in whispers anyone who goes  up there what is this  good they don't come back  descendants of these people are still  living up there on the mountain  do you know what we wouldn't have found  if we would have stayed on the trail  the waterfall  what is that oh my god  [Music]  what's a story people know but don't  talk about  except in whispers like a ghost story  don't bother them  and they don't bother us  [Music]  but anyone who goes up there what is  this  [Music]  they don't come back  it's happened before  [Music]  descendants of these people are still  living up there on the mountain  [Music]  they said they would be the foundation  on which a new nation would be built  you